c'est peut-être une révolution dans le
monde de la médecine un vaccin semble
prometteur le cancer du poumon on va
parler de ce sujet et je suis avec
Vincent Bordenave journaliste sciences
aux Figaro bonjour Vincent merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui on va parler de
l'internautes bien sûr à poser leurs
questions on y répond forcément au mieux
comme d'habitude vous le savez
Vincent donc je le disais on a donc un
vaccin contre le cancer du poumon
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
un vaccin c'est pas forcément contre un
cancer normalement on n'a pas encore un
vaccin contre un cancer mes chers mais
déjà pour un peu expliquer c'est sur
c'est pas quelque chose de intuitif de
de comprendre ce que c'est on a
l'habitude des vaccins contre les
pathologies comme la rougeole la
varicelle et puis bien sûr plus
récemment contre le covid 19 là il
s'agit de lutter contre des virus qui
vont infecter donc un individu un
organisme et entraîné en fait le système
immunitaire pour pour faire face à cette
infection alors dans le cancer on est
pas du tout dans le même dans le même
type de cas parce que ça arrive mais
c'est très rare qu'un cancer soit induit
par un agent pathogène c'est-à-dire par
un virus ça peut être le cas par exemple
pour avec le papillonnavier russe pour
le cancer de de l'utérus mais c'est pas
c'est pas le cas dans l'immense majorité
des cancers en tout cas pas dans le
cancer des poumons le cancer qu'est-ce
que c'est en fait
en vivant les cellules elles se divisent
à se reproduisent de cette manière là et
dans ces divisions il arrive qu'il y ait
des erreurs qui qui s'initient dans le
code génétique donc ça crée des
mutations la plupart du temps c'est
mutation pas de problème et des fois
elles vont des générer dans des cellules
cancéreuses et vont former vont former
ces tumeurs et donc ensuite de tumeurs
métastase etc et c'est dans ces moments
là que il y a des cancers donc les
cancers peuvent avoir des des ont
souvent des des causes extérieures qui
vont
augmenter la probabilité de voir
l'apparition de ces erreurs c'est
notamment le cas avec le tabagisme
l'alcool avec un certain nombre de
comportement de comportement à risque
mais on n'est pas du tout comme une
infection rend malade c'est un
comportement à risque va augmenter le
risque d'avoir d'avoir un cancer et donc
un vaccin contre un cancer en fait il
s'agit pas de vaccin s'agit d'un
traitement qui est basé sur la façon
dont fonctionne les vaccins les vaccins
c'est entraîné un système immunitaire à
faire face à une infection là ça va être
entraîné le système immunitaire à faire
face au cancer mais il faut que le
cancer soit déjà là en fait c'est un
entraînement qui est curatif on va pas
nous on va pas essayer de produire des
anticorps pour la faire simple c'est à
dire que contre le covid 19 par exemple
le vaccin arrive vocation à assimiler la
présence dans l'organisme de du virus du
saskov2 avec la protéine spy donc on a
beaucoup beaucoup parlé et donc
permettre à notre système immunitaire de
de produire des anticorps efficaces
contre cette protéine là on va enlever
cette étape là on va directement passer
à l'étape secondaire
qui essaye de lymphocyter les
lymphocytes c'est des cellules qui
visent à cibler les cellules malades de
notre organisme à les éliminer et donc
on va entraîner ces cellules c'est
lymphocytes T pour éliminer les cellules
cancéreuses et donc essayer de se
débarrasser du cancer alors j'ai pas mal
de questions de d'internautes Yannick
Richard qui est vraiment une question
une demande je me demande à quel point
la Casio du vaccin covid va éloigner les
gens qui ont besoin de ce vaccin alors
il faut faire attention parce que ce
vaccin c'est pas un vaccin préventif
c'est un vaccin curatif c'est ça alors
j'arrête tout de suite ce qui espérait
pouvoir se remettre à fumer des paquets
de cigarettes en se disant c'est bon
c'est un peu retrouver ce plaisir et et
ne plus risquer cancer du poumon on est
très très loin de ça on est sur un
vaccin
curatif et en plus au vu des résultats
qui ne sont montrés aujourd'hui
il ne remplace pas totalement la
chimiothérapie et donc d'autres
traitements beaucoup beaucoup plus
lourds qui plus est c'est pas un vaccin
qui c'est pas un traitement pour pour
être plus juste qui qui efficace pour
l'ensemble de la population c'est quand
même un certain nombre de limites qui
sont posées par par cette par ces
travaux mis en ligne enfin publier hier
dans dans une revue scientifique il y a
un certain nombre de promesses mais on
est très loin de des radiquer le cancer
du poumon et
même on est très loin d'avoir un
traitement efficace contre tous les
cancers du pont oui le résultat le gain
justement de ce vaccin alors en fait il
s'agit donc d'un vaccin qui est efficace
entre un type de cancer du poumon qui
est le cancer des fumeurs qui concerne
en 85% des des cancers des poumons mais
qui va être efficace seulement chez une
partie de la population c'est à dire que
dans le il y a des groupes au niveau des
systèmes immunitaires un peu de la même
manière que les groupes sanguins avaient
à Bo que tout le monde que tout le monde
connaît là on est sur des groupes qu'on
appelle H&A HLA de W négatif ou HLA
positif et donc ce ce traitement serait
chez les hlas de négatif qui
représentent 45% de la population donc
ensuite
quelle est quel est le gain chez les
personnes qui ont qui sont atteint d'un
cancer qui ont déjà subi une
chimiothérapie et une immunothérapie
il semblerait que le recours à ce vaccin
qui est quand même 6 injections
permettrait de à une meilleure
efficacité sur le long terme à un an que
de faire de recourir à une seconde
chimiothérapie je sais pas si si je suis
très clair pour résumer des patients qui
ont déjà subi une chimiothérapie
immunothérapie avoir ce cancer leur
permettrait d'éviter d'avoir recours à
une deuxième chimiothérapie et ça c'est
vachement important parce que la
chimiothérapie c'est un traitement qui
est très lourd qui a énormément d'effets
secondaires et en plus qui dans le cas
présent dans le cas de ce cancer et pas
et pas tout le temps efficace là on a un
gain efficacité qui augmentait de 1/3
c'est à dire que 41% des des personnes
dans le groupe dans le groupe test avec
ce vaccin en survécu contre seulement
25% pour ceux qui qui
bénéficient d'une chimiothérapie de
deuxième ligne c'est-à-dire que tout le
monde a sa chimio à la première étape
tout le monde a une chimie
il y a une il y a justement soit ce
vaccin soit une thérapie on a divisé
bonjour pour le présenter simplement ce
cheval là on parle aujourd'hui de
résultat des cinq cliniques les essais
cliniques ont rassemblé en
240 personnes je l'ai noté ici pour pas
l'oublier 219 personnes
qui ont été tirés au sort une partie une
partie en bénéficiait d'une seconde
chimiothérapie et une partie on
bénéficié donc de ce traitement et chez
ceux qui ont bénéficier de ce traitement
il y a 40 % de 41% des gens qui ont
survécu après un an contre seulement 25
% pour ceux qui étaient dans le groupe
parce qu'ils ont eu assez de personnes
pour valider
de ces travaux et que
une limite que pointe d'ailleurs les
auteurs eux-mêmes qu'on a pu joindre
aujourd'hui
pour pour le journal de demain
le recrutement on appelle recrutement
des individus pendant ces phases décès a
eu lieu pendant la pandémie ils ont dû
stopper stopper le recrutement avant
d'atteindre les objectifs c'était fixés
qui étaient de 360 individus donc ils
ont pas suffisamment de personnes et il
se trouve que une centaine de personnes
avaient bien réagi à luminothérapie qui
semble être l'élément déclencheur pour
valider pour valider ce vaccin donc ils
vont relancer dans les dans les
prochains mois une phase une phase 3
avec un public mieux sélectionné et
surtout plus de personnes pour vérifier
les résultats qui aujourd'hui sont
prometteur mais encore une fois je
répète on est quoi qu'il arrive pas sur
un traitement miracle qui nous soigne du
cancer du poumon ou qui nous prémunit du
cancer du poumon on est sur un
traitement qui permet à des personnes
malades de ne pas avoir un recours une
seconde fois la chimiothérapie ce qui
est un immense progrès pour les malades
il faut on passe le cacher mais il faut
pas non plus se tromper sur sur l'effet
d'annonce qu'il y a derrière le mot
cancer vaccin contre un cancer du poumon
oui et puis on est en 2023 actuellement
il ne sera pas prêt tout de suite oui
oui quoi qu'il arrive après il y a
toujours du temps là on a vécu une
période extraordinaire avec le covid 19
une accélération du du de la mission en
place et de la mission de marché de
vaccins mais pourquoi parce que tous les
laboratoires du monde étaient concentrés
vers cet objectif là donc on a eu une
puissance de frappe une recherche
scientifique
avec peu d'égal et on pourra je l'espère
parce qu'au vu des contexte on espère ne
pas revenir dans dans un dans un
contexte similaire on ne pourra pas
retrouver avant avant très longtemps
donc quoi qu'il arrive il faut du temps
pour pour mettre en place un vaccin
qu'on a une phase 3 en général il faut
bien être 5 ou 10 ans pour qu'il y a une
mise à une mission de marché donc on y
est pas tout de suite mais
quand bien même après les phases 3 on
élargit on passe à ce qu'on appelle une
face une phase 4 et une façon beaucoup
plus beaucoup de gens beaucoup plus de
gens qui a une surveillance en fait
c'est une pharmacovigilance des premiers
des premières personnes concernées par
par un traitement donc ça pour des
personnes à risque c'est on peut être on
peut les inclure très rapidement pour
les personnes les plus les plus
vulnérables ou les cas les les plus
pessimistes lesquels on a les plus
pessimistes il y a une question qui
revient souvent avec les vaccins c'est
est-ce que ça va coûter cher aux
personnes de se faire vacciner alors ce
vaccin là pour présenter son
fonctionnement il s'agit
de protéines en les scientifiques
des scientifiques de qui ont mis en
place ce vaccin qui font partie une
start-up française de Nantes et
en partenariat avec l'Institut
l'Institut Gustave Roussy la l'iger et
de spécialistes en des spécialistes en
France sur les cancers ou en fait
[Musique]
analyser
les cellules cancéreuses chez plusieurs
achats un certain nombre de
patients ont réussi à détecter des
protéines qui étaient communes à
l'ensemble de ces cellules et ils créent
en quelque sorte un cocktail protéique
avec 5 protéines cibles on va injecter
au
malade ce qui fait que le système
immunitaire va développer les fameux
lymphocytes contre ces protéines et
pourra pour ainsi cibler cibler les
cellules cancéreuses donc c'est une
technique qui est pas très éloignée d'un
certain nombre de vaccins qui sont déjà
qui sont déjà sur le marché qui est pas
particulièrement cher c'est un vaccin
protéique comme on en fait d'autres qui
nécessitent pas une une
qui nécessite pas une technologie très
avancée très avancé enfin si avancer
mais mais très très cher quoi
effectivement
les éolis aussi c'est une c'est c'est
une startup française
exactement qui qui travaille dessus
depuis un certain nombre d'années avec
je disais le partenaire avec l'iger
aussi qui suit beaucoup patient dans le
pays pour appeler quand même le cancer
du poumon ça est-ce que ça touche
beaucoup de monde en France est-ce qu'on
a des chiffres une incidence de 46 000
personnes nouvellement diagnostiquées
par an c'est les chiffres de 2018 là que
j'ai noté c'est environ 15% des cancers
mais c'est un des cancers les plus les
plus mortels
[Musique]
des résultats extrêmement prometteurs
très positifs
avant d'entrer dans la dans la phase 3
je rappelle comment fonctionne le vaccin
ARN on va injecter dans l'individu
le les informations génétiques qui vont
permettre à nos cellules de
générer la protéine Spike et aux
anticorps enfin la protéine cible et là
c'est la protéine Spike pour le pour le
pour le Sasco 2 bien entendu et donc
notre système immunitaire va réagir par
rapport à cette protéine et va créer des
anticorps puis les lymphocytes etc donc
là dans le cadre du cancer je reviens à
ce que je disais tout à l'heure le but
c'est d'injecter
c'est d'injecter dans l'individu
la formation génétique qui va permettre
de coder sur des protéines
ciblées sur sur les tumeurs et c'est là
qu'on va vers une révolution on n'y est
pas encore mais c'est notamment on y est
pas en tout cas avec le vaccin dont il
est suivi aujourd'hui mais c'est le cas
avec le le candidat vaccin proposé par
on a un traitement qui est
individualisé et qui est calculé pour
telle tumeur c'est à dire qu'on va on va
faire une on va procéder à une biosy
chez un individu malade on va donc
analyser sa tumeur et essayer dans dans
le patrimoine génétique et de constituer
un laboratoire les éléments qui
correspondent à cette humeur les
protéines qui sont cibles et qui
permettra à notre qui garantirait à
notre système immunitaire le maximum
d'efficacité contre contre la vie tumeur
et donc c'est c'est extrêmement
prometteur parce qu'on est on est sur un
traitement qui correspond à la tumeur
que vous avez dans dans votre organisme
et non pas à la tumeur type et donc qui
promet une meilleure une un taux de
réussite plus important donc on a
beaucoup pas mal de laboratoires qui
travaillent dessus principalement sur
les mélanomes parce que c'est plus
facile comme c'est des cancers comme
c'est des tumeurs qui sont au niveau de
la peau de de de de de procéder à des
analyses mais le cancer contre le du
foie aussi cancer du pancréage tout à
l'heure cancer des ovaires il y a on a
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de recherches
là-dessus là-dessus qui se développent
et les laboratoires sont
on rentre dans une nouvelle ère quoi
avec avec l'ARN une nouvelle aire plein
de promesses mais encore une fois on est
très loin des radications du cancer
c'est tous les laboratoires le disent
tous les scientifiques le dire on est
sur des traitement qui vont être
complémentaires de chimiothérapie de
traitement plus lourds qui va permettre
d'alléger quand même aller les patients
et ça c'est c'est pas rien et c'est pas
rien de le dire mais on n'est pas dans
un monde où on pourra se faire inoculer
un vaccin à l'âge de 15 ans j'en sais
rien
et ne pas avoir de cancer en grandissant
ça c'est encore la science-fiction
peut-être que ça arrivera mais on n'est
pas encore on n'est pas encore là dessus
le meilleur outil pour lutter contre le
cancer c'est la prévention et c'est
essayer de pas fumer par exemple de
sensibiliser sur les sur les
comportements à risque ce que ça
implique pourquoi est-ce que c'est
important de ne pas trop fumer de pas
fumer du tout c'est important de limiter
sa consommation de sa consommation
d'alcool en tout cas que quand on boit
qui a un risque il y a un risque de
cancer de donner ces informations aux
gens pour pour éviter pour éviter de
jamais malade excusez c'est que
en fait dans le futur on aura quasiment
un vaccin personnalisé c'est à dire
qu'en fait on peut en fait on nous fait
une biopsie et ensuite on nous dit alors
le vaccin c'est pour vous c'est composé
de 7 à ça et six mois plus tard je dis
quelque chose au pif on vous dit on vous
dit allez voici votre vaccin monsieur et
essayer c'est c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est proche sur lequel des
laboratoires travaillent je disais un
essai de Phase 2 moderna
merk il y a quelques quelques mois
publié dans des grandes revues avec des
résultats très positifs donc la phase 3
est en train de commencer on est on
était sur quelque chose de théorique là
on rentre dans quelque chose de pratique
c'est important mais même là-dedans en
fait on se rend compte que c'est pas
aussi simple mais alors c'est un peu le
la base avec l'immunité la biologie
c'est qu'il y a une règle générale c'est
comme dans tous les sciences
théorie de la relativité qui s'applique
partout mais en biologie
en une logique il y a énormément
d'exception et ces exceptions ne
comprend pas tout et on se rend compte
en fait que que ce principe là qui
devrait fonctionner à tous les coups
parce qu'on a fait une biopsie on a
récupéré les informations génétiques de
la tumeur on a injecté les protéines on
a injecté les informations génétiques
les petites informations
nécessaires pour que nos cellules
produits ces protéines et entraîner
notre système immunitaire et ben ça
fonctionne pas tous les coups
logiquement devrait avoir un taux de
100% vu que sur le papier c'est parfait
mais ça fonctionne pas tous les coups et
donc on comprend pas encore tout à fait
pourquoi il y a d'autres techniques donc
qui sont utilisées
sur lesquels on travaille pour pour
lutter contre le cancer encore une fois
quand on utilise le mot vaccin c'est un
peu impropre mais on va on va pouvoir
qu'on va appeler de de comme ça vaccin
contre le cancer notamment une technique
qui vise à stimuler en quelque sorte à
faire exploser en fait la tumeur on va
faire une une injection intra tumorale
donc directement dans la tumeur pour
faire un peu voler en éclat
[Musique]
un processus le faire voler en décalage
la protection que va développer la
tumeur autour ce qui va permettre à
notre système immunitaire de de pouvoir
rentrer dans cette tumeur et comprendre
quel est quelle est sa composition et à
partir de cette analyse développer une
réponse
une réponse efficace parce que c'est ça
le principal problème c'est que notre
système immunitaire quand il est
confronté à une tumeur il est bloqué par
plein de processus biologiques et il
n'arrive pas à développer la réponse
nécessaire donc le but c'est de réussir
à faire voler un éclat ça par des
injections de protéines intra entre un
tumorale il y a des essais cliniques qui
sont en cours plutôt des essais de phase
1 il y a des laboratoires qui
travaillent dessus notamment à Nantes
qui sont voisins de la start-up en
question donc on espère que en fait
c'est cette galaxie de traitement de
vaccin qui va permettre de de mieux de
mieux de mieux contrôler mais encore une
fois je le répète et peut-être que
enfin je répète parce que ça me semble
important le meilleur outil contre le
cancer c'est la prévention savoir d'où
ça vient
comprendre que notre action quand on est
jeune un impact sur sur ça quand on
vieillit donc c'est après il y a des
cancers qui arrivent parce que il y a
des maladies génétiques qui vont il y a
des il y a des maladies géniques qui
vont provoquer un certain nombre de
cancer il y a des cancers qui arrivent
dans des
dans le stade juvénile et donc les
cancers pédiatriques ça c'est quelque
chose différent mais la plupart des
cancers arrivent du haut vieillissement
des cellules et sont influencés par des
comportements à risque donc c'est pour
ça que la prévention reste pour le
moment le meilleur outil pour contre le
cancer oui c'est Véronique dans les
commentaires qui me dit mais vous
arrivez en bout de chaîne il faut il
faut agir sur l'alcool le tabac les
drogues le déduc qui lui dit très bonne
nouvelle ce vaccin on le rappeler quand
même ce vaccin on n'est pas sur un
traitement miracle ouais sinon on se
mettrait à fumée des gitans sur le
plateau non non on est très très loin de
ça et il faut vraiment le dire on n'est
pas sur l'entraînement miracle même pas
un traitement qui remplace la
chimiothérapie c'est un traitement qui
permettrait à certaines personnes donc
45% de la population je le répète de ne
pas avoir recours à une chimiothérapie
de seconde ligne c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
déjà une chimiothérapie et une
immunothérapie en première phase donc on
est sur des traitements très lourds et
c'est un traitement en plus qui est
composé de six injections avec de 3 à 6
semaines d'intervalle donc qui dure très
longtemps qui demande un long suivi et
on va pas annihiler le cancer le cancer
va rester là le but c'est de
d'accompagner le plus longtemps possible
et d'augmenter la durée de vie des
individus malades effectivement merci
beaucoup Vincent van Dave d'avoir été
avec nous un sujet à retrouver
d'ailleurs demain dans le journal du
Figaro exactement merci en tout cas
merci à vous hâte d'avoir été nombreux à
nous suivre et moi je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouveaux live sur figure live
votre prochain rendez-vous le lien
rendez-vous en ce moment d'ailleurs
c'est le point de vue vous pouvez
retrouver sur la page d'accueil du
Figaro et vous pouvez retrouver c'est le
buzz TV bonne soirée sur le Figaro